I'm scared you should be but I'm gonna
catch a lot of pumpkin Mon intro time
how's it going bros today we're going to
do some more Pokemon go hunting we have
some vehicles of transport PJ's here and
let's important vehicles so many
vehicles
this one doesn't worry I'm gonna take
this one PJ you got your longboard a
longboard
Michael you get them okay they do that's
the cutest you're welcome I haven't
tried any one of them nice I'm actually
scared this one looks terrifying it
looked like it could kill a baby
yeah alright we're gonna go outside
Cashion pokemons like the cool kids on
the block
come on nurse down there let's show them
how this is done
[Laughter]
I think I'll start sitting if I don't
come back it's not how much they love me
it's not reading here tell her I hate
him
[ __ ] hell this has a cake
[Music]
shut up stop laughing Jesus Christ this
thing is I'm scared so we're going I'm
going to get my penny board and gonna
use that instead I'm pretty sure my arm
is bleeding this is from falling before
I know it's supposed to look cool but if
you knew how I got this it's not it's
really nothing
stand still PJ all right we're catching
pokémon and hopefully I don't fall no I
got pretty bored I think I will anyway
so you can't go more than 20 miles per
hour yeah is that correct
oh yeah I'm okay with that I'm actually
okay with that so now we're gonna be in
a photo shoot apparently okay they're
taking pictures of people playing
Pokemon go and time to be model
so literally everyone is on their phone
playing Pokemon go right now because
your game is out in UK but the servers
are fried doesn't really works I think
we're gonna give up
I mean I've given up if you fall off the
horse you gotta get back up I'm not
afraid I know all the [ __ ] pokemons
are oh come on it's my favorite one
we're going welcome home we're going
going
[Music]
ladies think I want their number hell no
I'm playing Pokemon go
[Music]
get you thank you lady better hurry up
you
we're going to Hub Park it's a lot of
pokemons there does anyone know where
the park is Michael it's your turn are
you ready I'm really are you ready grab
the phone I need the eggs to hatch
oh don't worry you're fine right stated
stated camera I need you to confirm that
you're fine I need you say I am fine and
I'm not going to shoot him I'm fine
little nut fella cool
[Music]
where the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] park man
I'm tired of walking but you haven't
been walking shut up
got a drowsy while I did that a big deal
the prog is up there now the park is
down there I know this town inside out
every step of the way
so he's skating on that thing but we're
just following him around for hours and
hours walking and also like I said
before I hate Pokemon
[Music]
[Music]
I made it finally oh we're gonna catch a
lot of pokemons over here a lot of
Pokemon let's go boys
[Music]
[Music]
what's up don't [ __ ] talk to me the
servers are down
the servers are down why are we here
[Music]
why are we here
[Music]
you